je vais avoir une pensée pour Lola
victime d'un crime abominable en tant
que député je me joins à l'émotion
nationale mais en tant que père je
m'incline devant la douleur d'une
famille brisée et un consolable
l'horreur n'a pas de nom la barbarie n'a
pas d'excuse et si la pudeur aurait dû
m'empêcher de vous poser cette question
la colère n'a pu m'en dissuader
monsieur le ministre elle s'appelait
Lola elle avait 12 ans et elle avait
toute la vie devant elle mais par
faiblesse de la République elle a vécu
la douleur la torture la barbarie en
plein Paris
par le laxisme de votre politique
d'immigration cet enfant a été martyrisé
violet tué par une clandestine qui
faisait pourtant l'objet d'une
obligation de quitter le territoire
français
le défaut d'exécution de ses décisions
de justice
rend votre ministère responsable de ses
drames et je regrette d'avoir à vous
l'imputer mais les chiffres de votre
administration sont implacables
80% des auqtf ne sont toujours pas
exécutés en France et le nombre de
retours forcés vers l'Algérie a chuté de
94% entre 2020 et 2021
lola a perdu la vie parce que vous
n'avez pas procédé à l'expulsion de
cette ressortissante qui n'avait plus
rien à faire ici voilà la lourde
conséquence de votre inaction enfin je
ne sais pas si la justice des hommes
pourra être à la hauteur de
l'impardonnable mais je réclame un droit
au procès pour Lola la France ne serait
tolérée l'irresponsabilité pénale de ces
bourreaux qui n'ont leur place que dans
l'avion ou en prison oui
l'expulsion des délinquants étrangers
doit être une obligation et automatique
car une fois de plus le lien entre
immigration incontrôlée